[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome it's Tuesday I'm Eric as
the name says there that's John Luke hi
what's up John we what are we playing
today we're playing Uncharted The Lost
legacy which comes out today yes it is
out $39.99 on PlayStation 4 of course oh
you're gonna show them the finale I'm
gonna just write to the ending yeah now
we're gonna do chapter 4 which is the
open-ended level yeah similar to the
Madagascar level from a thief's end
gotcha so basically as the title
mentions we're not gonna spoil any story
for anyone obviously as you mentioned
we're gonna explore kind of this
open-world area in chapter 4 so don't be
worried too much about spoilers
obviously I have beaten the game so feel
free to ask questions yep exactly I'll
be here checking the chat out YouTube
and twitch if you guys have questions
about the game obviously ask and I will
pass that information or question on to
John Luke cuz he is more of the expert
of Uncharted than I am and on that note
he has done a history of Uncharted so if
you're kind of like not sure you know
how and Uncharted has evolved over time
or how the story has gone over time who
some of these characters are that we're
about to see you know Chloe and Nadine
you should check that out I'll post that
link in the chat so you guys can check
that out either you know later hopefully
maybe now at the same time but probably
later is better so yeah that that's
pretty cool it's like a 30-minute one so
not yeah not too long not like history
of Sonic which was like 50 minutes now
but if you want to get a thirty familiar
within charted it's a good way to kind
of do that and John who's working on
history of every two weeks so he'll be
you know doing various games that are
coming out I think Assassin's Creed is
the next one yes so if you're curious
about you know the evolution of history
of of Assassin's Creed you can also get
ready to tune into that one but for now
I'm going to say you guys the link for
the history of Uncharted as we start
chapter 4 here yeah I saw Bob Jones ask
Alan I took me to beat the game exactly
6 hours is my playtime according to the
game which sounds about right
nice harvest I'm hyped for destiny to
well actually be on that small Segway
will actually be doing destiny to next
week when the PC beta is out it'll be me
and you John Luke just so you know
surprise okay cool alright I'll prep for
that next week yes this game is on ps4 a
TI mine design I think it's only obvious
for ya though it's for enlisted Scott
pro sport Pro Sport is similar to what
to expect from like the pro support for
keep send we don't really do much in the
way of analysis videos that kind but uh
ooh but uh digital foundry that's how
crazy I don't like that I always
recommend so I know if you can hear it
in the game but you hear this little one
yeah sound that came from my controller
that is tells me what a treasures nearby
and that is a to the little necklace she
has a little bracelet yeah yeah that is
the thing that lets me find when
treasures nearby and I had to actually
do a side quest to get it it is the side
quest we actually do in this chapter
okay um so I did not find this one
before because I didn't have it at this
point god yeah you can turn that off -
also you can do the ocean just look for
it yourself
yes if you don't want a few one do the
quest but you don't want necessarily use
it you can go turn it off in the menu
that's good that's good that the options
there harvests we are not playing on a
ps4 Pro currently yeah - I'm we make a
video on the junker town and overwatch I
mean when the junker town maps available
to play I'm sure me and Joey will be
streaming that so you can look forward
to that I don't think there's a there's
been a date set for that though and I
think it's playable though at Gamescom
apparently so if it might be sooner than
we think you know with the Wizards but
back to uncharted we are navigating here
looking for treasure
oh man one wood man finding all these
yeah and I mean the cool thing too is I
think I want to say like before you
loaded this map it kind of told you how
many treasures you had and now you got
two more so like completionists at any
point I can pull up well first off I can
pull my phone and you take photos in
this game at certain points which is
kind of cool
the game also does have the the actual
photo mode that you descend and like a
lot of PlayStation 4 games have like
horizon had that so there's a map here
kind of see where I am this is the whole
section you're kind of going back and
forth right now I need to get to that
tower and also just so you guys know
review wise we did review this game got
a 9 out of 10 whoo-wee that you're a
risky man there but I'm sure you already
knew that was gonna work yeah
Lost Legacy yeah review by Miguel
Concepcion on nine out of ten oh you're
just getting treasures man this way I
hear it's very subtle but I hear it you
might as well get them all right yeah
yeah see here oh cool I was like man I
uh Harvey asked what my destiny gave one
character carry over destiny to I mean
the appearance wolf but that's about it
oh no it's on the I Oh sneaky
coin I guess last one was like a
treasure box
yeah goo basically you'll see me every
day from now on I'll be pretty much
hosting every livestream sans the lobby
we might even see John Luke on the lobby
tomorrow we'll see I'm not positive on
that I think yeah so if you guys weren't
aware we do the lobby every Wednesday
it's our weekly kind of gaming talk show
where we talk about the biggest news
reviews and hot topics I guess and since
Mike is away for like a couple weeks I
think Peter Brown is gonna go some one's
got a laser sight on you it's gonna host
I'm gonna ignore that for now and John
Luke might be a little special guest for
a couple weeks which that means I have
the fun job of switching yeah I survived
last week so it's fine I think it's fine
oh no what did we date what do we
deserve this I don't know I flexed my
power I guess no that's not really it
hard rescues a mod in here there should
be a couple of mods I would assume
philanthropy which is been Jenko up I
show up and a little bit where are you
going I'm I gotta climb this tower Oh
oh yeah also fun fact John Luke is
currently playing no HUD mode which is
also an option oh I'm not actually oh
you're not I can't turn it on though no
I was thinking about it I'll turn it on
why not all right no HUD uh let's see it
was a display this no I saw a hug there
I saw it there there we go so I just
Sables everything we'll see how that
turns out I think you'll be fine
you told me right before the stream
you'd be fine
well you're so see the shinies right for
your treasures I show you visually I
mean it's bad so yeah so I was asking
you this earlier before we start
streaming like for somebody who hasn't
played Uncharted do you feel like this
is a good kind of because this is a
standalone experience right like do you
feel like this is a you know like a good
game to invest into I guess so farm
button yeah I think
this game does a great job being like
its own standalone thing if you've never
played Uncharted but are interested in
this you'll you'll be fine uh-huh and
are you like do you feel like there's
any like story beats you're missing like
the like because you kind of have like
as someone who's played all the in
cartage do you have a little bit more of
an intimate relationship I guess with
some of these characters do you feel
like it's still like fine like if I
started playing this game I think so I
mean certainly make nods and references
to past events this game does take place
after four so it does spoil a tiny bit
elements you know if you've never played
four but like Chloe and Nadine are like
their relationship is brand-new even
though they are existing characters
they're their relationship with each
other is brand new so you're not
necessarily missing any thing in terms
like character development on there and
I'm sort of like the the stuff that goes
into as far as like their their personal
issues all are very kind of like
self-contained to this game I'd say
what's up hacker zhx Mickey what's up
thanks for tuning in
James Cornwall this is an early access
the games I actually out now so if
you're interested in playing it out on
ps4 today or it's probably been out
since last our last night / 12 a.m. ish
but it's $39.99 and it is a standalone
game as we had just mentioned it does
also have multiplayer which you can
probably try climbing into a match or
two at the end of the stream later just
to show you guys that off but it's just
a charge for multiplayer a charter for
multiplayer comes with a couple extra
stuff there's also a survival mode which
was also added into for later because I
don't need these button prompts and when
you turn that HUD back on I might have
to do it sorry
I totally threw you under the bus to do
no HUD there no your that that's fine I
wanted to try it because I like playing
games at HUD but this game maybe he's in
built for quite the same way TI mine
design we're excited for Mario rabbits
will be live streaming that actually
next week on
Tuesday so you know obviously come back
check that out we'll also have some
stuff up maybe later this week
think embargo lifts later this week also
hacker please stop spamming or I'll have
to Cooper's who else is upset they
missed it that's classic I am it's like
it's not worth it it's not worth all the
hassle yeah I mean so for those curious
are interested about this is classic it
came back available last night best buy
it was like 10 or 11 and it sold out in
like 20 minutes and then I think you
tried this morning like a 10:00 a.m. a
Walmart and like it sold out in like 5
min 5 minutes or something Walmart and
Target sold out like two minutes yeah
it's like it's insane alright so
basically now you kind of unlocked more
stuff I guess that you can do right yeah
so by climbing this tower we've we found
all these different points that we can
go explore and there are these three
different towers we eventually have to
climb and the cool thing is you can
actually climb them in any order so cool
very very freeform James Cornwell with
another question so is a so can you play
cross play with uncharted 4 multiplayer
or is it a separate experience I'm
pretty sure it's cross play I would
equate this to Halo 3 ODST oh yeah sort
of like also a $40 game that came with
you know its own standalone thing that
was about like six eight hours and then
it also came with a separate disc that
just had like every the entire like halo
3 multiplayer experience so that was
kind of a very similar package that was
great I remember getting that was
awesome because I played a lot of
Uncharted I'm sorry uh halo 3 with my
friends and we would do like LAN parties
and stuff but the problem is you always
don't have enough disks and so buying
ODST you get like an extra disc and
extra multi now we basically have an
extra multiplayer disc without having to
buy a full copy of yeah
yellow three so we're gonna go to pick a
spot any spot let's go to let's go to
that Triton down the TI mine design will
be here for about sixty to ninety
minutes depending on the area and
multiplayer obviously so if you have to
jet real quick and come back that's
totally fine we'll be here thanks for
tuning in obviously
yeah sorry Ishmael unfortunately those
current locations are sold out but
someone was saying like Amazon might
have some I don't know thought
apparently sold out at like what real
morning or so 1:00 in the morning that's
what I heard I heard that Amazon was
like selling a melon 1:00 in the morning
what a great time and that's the thing
is like it's for us it's like wow it's
like 1:00 2:00 in the morning and we're
on the west coast so the East Coast is
like 4:00 in the morning for them like
that's that's really something really
it's terrible poor timing a sparkling
cyanide basically saying love how didn't
Indo gave this basically no heads-up
terrible feeding those scalpers yeah
pretty much yeah right that's that's
kind of the problem I feel like it's I
don't know it's that weird question of
like okay does Nintendo shoot Nintendo
only be you know making X amount because
they want that you know that special
feeling that you got it or should they
just sell enough that like everyone that
actually wants one has one instead of
having to pay like I think I saw one on
Amazon because like you know Amazon also
it has third-party sellers and there's
like 240 it was like it was like oh
sorry that was at Ned's classic but the
nez classic was like 240 I clearly like
that's like quadruple Christ and the
business logic of not wanting to just
make enough for everyone to get one and
be happy because they're gonna sell more
systems right yeah and it's like in this
case they're not helping themselves by
at least financially by selling less
because it's not like those who doesn't
go anywhere
go shot it again evil airs oh you know
I'm doing you know I'm doing that it's
because I've been playing Assassin's
Creed you move down the trigger to run
okay that is why I'm interesting why am
i shooting game looks great though I've
been distracted by a Nintendo Super
Nintendo classic stock here but oh yeah
this is the whole game looks great but
this level in particular has like a lot
of variety that's really good to show
off what's up come we're all Tetsu we
are yeah we were definitely not doing
any spoilers here we're just doing i
think it's chapter 4 its kind of more
open world we're just exploring kind of
pull it grabbing some treasure so
definitely there's no story spoilers so
don't be worried about that yeah this is
this is by far the least story spoiler
level wide site in the whole game Vitara
asking how is the open-world and
uncharted good I I think it it takes
that stuff from for and does it a lot
better open-ended and it's kind of I
almost would love to see an insurance
tile game that makes this almost the
whole game good where you just have
these big like massive open areas it one
can kind of explore your leeway and then
when you want you can keep going it kind
of solves the problem that like true
open world games have where like story
and pacing kind of gets like ruined all
right we're gonna get some action here
that's that part we were checking out
earlier before you started oh nice okay
okay
hi ps4 addictions good to have you in
chat thanks for stopping by
yeah no worries tomorrow it was actually
I it's more of a good on John Luke for
you know because we we had a brief
discussion we're like do we want to do
in Charlie tomorrow I mean like it's
it's such a big game we should do it and
he's like well you know if we're gonna
do it
there is luckily this open area that we
can explore and you know not spoil any
story I'm like okay we should do that
because it'll still showcase the game
showcase like you know pretty much I'm
sure you're still doing some of this
kind of stuff during the story parts of
the game and went on it so yeah it was a
close one there so on the combat end
it's pretty much what you expect from
from for there is a little bit more
emphasis on stealth you can get like a
silenced pistol oh nice
that was not it was available in the
game's multiplayer but wasn't in the
single-player for Uncharted for short
range huh oh how do you guys see you
there's still a little dumb what's up
Nikki jeez I'm gonna put your last name
Georgia Georgie close hopefully I was
close sorry if I butchered your last
name but hello thank you for tuning in
okay butts are only a little dumb it's
pretty bad she literally ran in front of
him and he was like what was that noise
but it happens in a lot of games right
so it's not like it's just this one so
how's your a I like co-op here how's
Nadine a just fine yeah it's pretty like
she got your back pretty well she's got
your back she'll do some damage in a
firefight but doesn't feel like she's
getting anyway or anything like that I
think it's the the right level of that
you kind of want your AI partner in this
kind of game
gravy biscuits asking we do yakuza
kiwami or everybody's guessing golf not
gold next week I was thinking about
Yakuza but I'm not sure we'll see yeah
we might get Peter in on that he did do
the review it's possible I've never
played it you choose a game but I feel
like there there's so much my thing that
I really need to I feel like like the
one part I do like about that game is
not has nothing to do with the story
stuff it's just all about that
you know nightlife and like going we're
the city and like just doing like weird
stuff like I'm gonna go do karaoke gonna
go visit a strip club yeah
I'm gonna go went to one of those like
was it like an AV kind of thing I'm
gonna get a trophy for watching softcore
porn essentially right like the weird
the weird stuff totally weeds oh yeah
thank you guys all for tuning in we are
live every day at 11:00 obviously
GameSpot live Lobby on Wednesdays Monday
Tuesday Thursday Friday you haven't or a
sub you should consider doing that so
that you guys can get notified when we
go alive but also because we do cool WOD
content like shoot boots history of
Uncharted we're going hot
oh good night oh nice shot
oh this shotguns doing work jump get
rekt see it Oh snakes I like it
good work there's still somebody I guess
I just hear gunfire
can your gunfire I don't I don't see
anything no you're right Oh dark gray
there great labor I'm not it's not nice
there is multiplayer in this game but
it's like uncharted for a traditional
multi yeah or not so much like I can't
coop with him or anything like that if
that's kind of what you're asking there
is a survival mode which is a co-op mode
okay but there's no split-screen dying
that's been a while
and I feel like they're just never gonna
do it because they just don't sell
enough copies of a game I think Diablo
has it it's not really split-screen you
share the screen I think they said I
think they backpedaled with uh inside
the next halo gala will bring back a
split screen because that was such a big
deal for people yeah well it's because
every game up until that point right was
you know everyone has their land
experience and land memory multiplayer
it's also with them ends to campaign
like I would play with my brother my
friend like invite them over and play
the campaign together right like then
it's like oh you want to play a
cooperative campaign you have to do it
online mm-hmm at which point there was
no way for me to play because it's not
like okay well I could tell my friend
hey go buy an xbox one and another copy
he's not gonna do that so it's like I
guess we just won't play a low fives
campaign together mm-hmm
Mike back on so JT Savage saying is it
different from four where was more of a
linear open-world yes yeah so it's only
this chapter um well actually so you do
get go back to this
section four it for another chapter
that's pretty small part but I open the
map here like I have all these different
three points but I can go to them in any
order I want which is pretty cool it's
but this is primarily the only chapter
you can kind of do that yes this is the
only chapter which is why I was saying I
would love to see a game that actually
like took this idea and made it like the
full game maybe like something where
it's like um it's each level is a
different open-world area kind of think
of like the original Far Cry or Christ
right where we're just like bigger areas
with yeah breeze of big areas that's
like one like chapter mission or went on
which is basically exactly I'm not
saying I want to charted to be like full
open world one massive map a series of
kind of open-ended house
so Jordan leva liebe put potentially
sorry for the last name butchering so
that's kind of answering your question
about does this have an open world it
doesn't in like the traditional sense I
guess but it does a little bit at least
in this chapter where the you know as he
opened the map you saw that he can go to
you know different points of interest it
doesn't force you to do one you know
then another than another you could go
to any one of these never guys like
fortress or temples
so yeah so it's like kind of yeah Anna
grant can't wait to get their hands on
this it's a good one
as mentioned before nine out of ten yelp
review by I'm Miguel Concepcion
I know that most of the people that got
their hands on this early in the office
all seem to be pretty happy pretty yeah
pretty about the game I'm not gonna talk
about it because it's the end of the
game but the final chapter I found to be
really really good like if you're
looking for like a really good sort of
like Uncharted spectacle that that final
chapter is awesome I gotta make a try
it's a little simple puzzle here Matta
like a Resident Evil take some good
puzzles in this one no they're not
they're not terribly complex but they're
ashc a punk new tomb raider was the I
remember when Uncharted first came out I
know it so when they showed it off at a
3 2006 everyone kept calling it dude
raider it's a dude raider but then just
seems like everyone forgot about that
when the unsure the Tomb Raider reboot
came out cuz everyone's like oh it's
it's uncharted with a girl and I was
like Tomb Raider came out first guys
don't you remember what I would call
dude Raider how quickly everyone forgets
how it goes man that's how it goes the
Internet is fickle and they are often
forgetful I think it's
oh man Miguel Alfama boy yeah this is
out you can buy all today $39.99 yes for
its gorgeous daughter with me he's
getting a little bit into into the
touches on the back story Chloe's dad
which kind of becomes a like a thing of
her character in this game kind of dives
into the backstory with her her dad and
me sir explains why she chose his life
nice so here's a question for you did
you feel that it was repetitive because
Edward Lin and YouTube chat basically
said that she felt that there's a lot of
unused production assets from the main
game it's all felt so repetitive and
there's a keel that you I didn't think
so
I mean it's not new in the sense that
they're not doesn't feel like the next
evolution of enchanted or necessarily
evolving the mechanics in a significant
way but I don't think it felt like it
was recycling or anything or not they're
not repeating environments from
uncharted 4 they're not you know it's
new story beats those new characters
like they're nothing about it
necessarily felt like oh this is just a
I think if you were maybe expecting it
to be something greater than uncharted 4
it's not really what this game is
I mean this game you know it's 40 bucks
they've only been making it for about
like a year when you kind of think about
in that context this game is really
impressive what they were able to pull
off yeah nothing nothing it's not gonna
blow your mind or anything I don't think
necessarily except for that final
chapter I like that final chapter yeah
the final chapter actually did some
really cool stuff that's awesome so mr.
raisin I mean - you're like your
question basically asking is this worth
getting I think that if you enjoy the
entire series
and you know that style of gameplay you
know the action-adventure the puzzles
all those things I think that not only
would we as GameSpot I mean as Miguel's
point giving it a nine out of ten would
tell you to get it
John Luke also will probably be like
yeah you should probably get it but
that's totally you know like are you
into this kind of game obviously it's
still 39.99 and everyone's kind of like
value proposition or like how much
they're willing to spend on the game is
different right so but but I think you
said roughly six to eight hours it's
about six hours for a six hour which is
about the length of the first Uncharted
game okay I'm not bad yeah thanks ash
Kay Punk I will do my best to continue
reading chat but thank you for the kind
words that's what we're trying to do
here
I like that oh hey there's a guy like
what happened you notice turn off take
your Safety's off man some stuffs
happening oh man just sneak out of here
before that's no fun I'll try and I'll
turn into some confident I guess also
for those like here's about actual
Uncharted story as I had mentioned
earlier we do have a history of
Uncharted done by John Luke himself so
if you want to learn more about Nathan
Drake and kind of like where that
story's gone along it's a great way to
kind of get all that wealth of
information it is thirty minutes but you
know it's it's all good stuff and expect
more of that to come every two weeks
your next one's Assassin's Creed so stay
tuned for that one
but for now I'm charted man where's this
guy alright gotta be careful of this guy
the armored yeah and a shotgun so I'm
gonna feel like rip his helmet off first
so we're gonna be careful one a james
Cornwell saying loves that is longer
than just a three hour DLC yeah it's
it's a standalone experience so I would
hope that it's longer than three hours
but you know at the same time that's not
I can't you can't always view things
just based off the time
because I feel like if you have a good
three-hour experience it's still good
right right not always about because you
add time to something yeah and this game
I think has the perfect length like when
it was over it was like all that was
that was exactly didn't out States
welcomed bring in the big guns
yeah you're just earning trophies left
and right yeah really good that's what I
want
yes it Nellie the review has been up for
like some flat was it last week end of
last week yeah last Thursday so check
that out if you haven't checked out the
review a video review obviously on
YouTube text on gamespot.com
video reviews awesome GameSpot calm so
you could you could get both if you if
you liked it to do that what's in here
Oh someone from games watch hat doesn't
feel like Uncharted deserved a 9
necessarily and feels that IGN got it
more right with a 7 and a half but I
don't like his comparison I don't really
like so much because so he said $40 for
six hours whereas something like Witcher
blood and wine was twenty dollars for 20
hours totally different kind of game I
feel like like I feel like yeah that's
such a hard thing to compare I mean I
think if you're trying to look at games
purely from like a dollar two value
proposition that's one thing but you
know you look at like the level of not
to say that like a Witcher doesn't have
a good presentation of graphics but you
know the cutscenes and the mocap and the
like the facial detail like their beds
this is clearly a step above most games
and like you're kind of also paying for
that presentation you're paying for that
Naughty Dog story you know which I think
like you have to take that into account
when you're buying a game like this but
that was cane towel 11 in games archives
but he didn't mention they do right
you know witty dialogue like likable
characters so I mean exactly it's it's
tough it's always tough to compare two
different games to different genres
different price points it's always gonna
be difficult but yeah this is a
lock-picking mini game that is new to
the series account whatever adds a
little variety but I can take it or
leave it
I don't hate it but I don't necessarily
it wasn't like begging for the
lock-picking minigame to be introduced
to ensure didn't necessarily sweet but
he also he or she also says to each
their own I enjoy I enjoyed and charted
for once couldn't play through it again
platforming has no risk to it it's just
filler I mean again it's really hard to
compare like weird three to uncharted 4
I don't think that's like it's like
someone who's saying do they mention
Nathan Drake by name there you go boom
Drake I don't forget about your boy ash
Kay Punk boy do I regret buying an Xbox
one hey at least you weren't like my
friend who bought an Xbox one X and I'm
like why did you buy an xbox one X or no
xB pre or sorry pre-order I'm like why
did you buy a one Xbox one X I I
personally don't understand at least in
the in the current like what is going to
be available right and it's not like
he's a huge sports a fan or anything
like that I just don't feel like they're
4k TV I think he does
okay that's fine maybe it was like you
know wanna play Assassin's Creed in 4k
or something but I guess alright so
here's a one of these little optional
puzzles we can do so I got ring all
these bells see if I can do it oh nice
is this like overwatch or you can play
the Futurama song house
gube has a question do you know how many
trophies are - not that work oh hey miss
miss one didn't I like that one didn't
ring or something this one this one yep
got it there we go and there wasn't an
order for that right no you just had you
just gotta hit them all in a certain
amount I'm sick of this little token
here some bummer I wasted most of my um
silence there any more on that book
whatever okay I'll get more it's okay
you wanted to do it in style
okay that was a waste though I know you
got that muscle memory all right another
trophy yeah we took four days check here
how many oh that's a good point uh he
basically says I had honestly pay 20
bucks for something mania than 40 for a
six-hour long game but again hard to
compare the two I do think that sounding
mania $20 and especially if you have a
switch is a pretty good right value
proposition there you're getting a lot
of a lot of gameplay a lot of nostalgia
if you played the old games good time to
say that if you're ever wondering about
Sonic and how that involves guess what
John Luke's got your back on that too
because he's got history of Sonic that
was a little bit longer but in YouTube
we do have kind of like links to those
specific games if you like like you know
Sonic 2 or Sonic and Knuckles and stuff
like that so check that out too
that's out there are the puzzles hard
we need harder puzzles no they're not
too hard okay they're good I like them
but they don't really get over there ah
take a photo take a photo is one playing
with their butt or like picking hair out
of the other one I can look at this
photo
BAM
which they did something with the photo
mechanic I mean that photo mechanic I
mean there is the actual photo could
turn on photo mode and then you know do
all this fun stuff right okay pose you
got her in oh she's awesome
I really like the I like what people
have done with photo mode like horizon
it's just rising stuffs cool like so
this you can see if I can you see it
change the facial expression
that's really weird that's so weird I
don't know how I feel about that I ask
duck face through a duck face man they
really went all out
gross wink into the wink turn off the
characters crease the saturation Kannan
underscore asking are there different
outfits you can unlock not that I'm
aware of and some film brain always got
that film brain k-town telling me
basically that he bought pro day one
it had no games on launch and he also
pre-ordered the One X you can't like I
just won this where the the time of day
to just kind of Nate I think for me to
like the problem the harder part for me
to swallow is like and I don't have a 4k
TV with HDR so it's like not only would
I be investing in a console but also TV
yeah right and I know that you you know
at some point not only got a pro but you
got a 4k TV
I got one during Black Friday
yeah maybe I gotta wait for that hot
Black Friday sale cuz like a 4k TV with
HDR at like a good size of like it's
good potentially 55 or something inches
probably think mine takes 40 yeah oh it
was like I was like yeah I got um the
y-guy is I think the same model is the
one we have oh sorry did you often I
totally asked it alright there's I think
you said there's different outfits you
can unlock righteous I don't think so
okay don't think so no I don't think
there are they have all the cool like
filters stuff that you unlock wants to
beat the games like for had okay but I
don't think there are altering outfits
that I'm aware of
James Cornwell saying that he spent a
lot of time photo mode in charge for
sure you enjoyed this one especially
with all those faces you can bracelet
that you're ready oh yeah right so I
already have it but this is where you
would get the bracelet and this is um
puzzle you guys so you gotta get all the
tokens and they're all listed right
there so on the map now I have them all
marked and I can go try and get them in
there like a little optional thing you
can do which is cool I would still buy a
1080p TV coupe because they're so cheap
Joey case KS 8000 KS 8000 yes oh the
monkeys the model does he have the same
one I don't know if he does but I have
the same model as the one in the office
I'm pretty sure Zanelli telling me that
sauna mania has less than 15 euro and
steam which he thinks is crazy good
value that's good value it's a good game
we all about value
I don't want your TV from like New York
the shipping alone would probably be
worth more than the TV potentially nice
luck picking
well that gun looks cool yeah that will
scoop yeah all right all right have you
done another tower thing yet now we're
gonna head to ones
I guess in this case I'm Naveen in your
Cloe here we go
all right is there action at every one
of these towers I believe so
[Music]
people need take a go up a little bit he
stir West PC is the best all right I'm
on I'm not gonna go into console pc Wars
all right yeah gotta use the wench
all right that goes pretty far
Nadine oh you got to do it at least it
was consistent and how you pulled it as
funny as it looks
oh yeah alright so we're in our second
like temple area of the three better on
this open world style mission so Ti
it's where the name voice allah comes
from boy ami strike in there
thanks Nadine well that's unfortunate
guessing scripted oh yeah classic
intruder right there oh also uh if you
want something kind of funny and
uncharted related Miguel did a supercut
of all the like yeah shits and cuss
words and just kind of like funny
moments and uncharted so that's also on
our YouTube at first I thought it was
gonna get old and it was actually it
didn't get old and it's kind of funny I
enjoyed it so I don't know it's there if
you guys want to watch it idiots for
leaving their climbing gear
yeah I'm sure proton saying internal
games are always so graphically
impressive I wish I could play that on
PC will look even better than right in
one day seems like like if anything
Microsoft has kind of forged that
relationship a little better but that
makes obvious sense right sure
unfortunately PlayStation is still
pretty picky when it comes to playing
with others so they can kind of do
because they're top dog right now but I
feel like at e3 though I don't like that
no III Nintendo was top dog at e3 as far
as I'm concerned how do you guys record
livestream your Nintendo switch it's
pretty easy I mean there's an HDMI out
of your switch dock now there's not a
way to do it handheld though right
because we tried certain things with
like USB see cables and I think even our
one of our leads in game tech Jimmy
thing I think he asked if it was
possible and it is not currently so like
the only way you'd be able to get
anything from like handheld is like you
know if you had a camera or like your
phone camera or anything like that to
take a to take a shot at my screen like
people have like jerry-rigged stuff for
3d s's as well I mean we're fortunate
enough to have like a 3ds Deb kit that
has like an HDMI out but why is he like
send you three s to a guy
ode of like mod a hundred bucks low mod
4 yeah oh yeah guns blazing
oh whoa oh my comers gone oh I don't
even see the bullet
well that's number one try again here
keeping count I don't know it's it's a
it's this isn't the type of game I would
keep count of but like whenever we ever
maybe get blood-borne 2 or something
maybe we'll have a death counter oh yeah
III streamed my entire playthrough
blood-borne when I got that like I ended
up with the tremor my final death count
like a hundred twenty or someone girl
shows her right in the like one of them
menu I think it does but it's like my
manual cow I might have been off
immanuel immanuel count of it and I
think I would think I had more than that
but loved one was my first like Souls II
game so that's to be expected the best
was like when everyone because we had it
early right when everyone was whoa that
was weird
you're a crazy man
you don't care cuz you open a launcher
and they just have a gun I'm gonna say
like I should have saw giblets at that
point still good on death counter on
everything not necessary only when it's
appropriate cool yeah James Cornwall
basically also saying yeah I think they
said in charter for would have a short
story do you see what they decided to
make it longer and a standalone
experience that was kind of it yeah this
was originally meant to just sort of be
like a sure it'll you'll see it kind of
became its own thing what does it do the
obvious yeah oh this is the one of the
more fun houses
that's elaborate whoa it's kind of feels
like one of those like Zelda shrines
that's cool I like that did you die the
first time you did that not on this one
so you actually don't die you just get
hit you go back to the head I think
you're on a hard difficulty you'll
probably die okay but normally just kind
of get whacked in the head
so this uncharted is $40 $39.99 Ryan
Dunn saying right now he's that guy that
always survives on 1% health online that
does happen if you watch a lot of like
feel like when you watch a lot of videos
and you're like oh this guy he's gonna
die he's gonna die and then like they
just never die and there's like oh he
just got lucky just got lucky that's how
I felt about like watching a lot of
people playing darts so it was like but
you know yes like oh he's totally gonna
die and then like he's someday somehow
it was like
oh shoot there's more now
palms are sweaty
no nice nailed it
no what's better than one Tomb Raider
Khloe and indeed they're good pair stay
it's definitely like a highlight of the
game is they've third dynamics really
really good
hello [ __ ] in cats sit that right
all right more axe guys what's up your
key bar welcome glad you could tune in
to some hot uncharted at lost legacy
action currently not spoiling any story
and doing chapter 4 where it's more of
an open world three of these temple
areas this one is at least by far puzzle
wise harder than the last one kind of
cool to see this you see John Lee gets
hit oh god I'm so ominous okay
that would have hurt John Luke nearly
got sliced but he didn't all right well
you can die so we were just showing you
guys that you can die on normal oh yeah
totally intentional
I sure your cube are just gave you a
shout out but welcome again Welker in
town that looks more like a mallet than
an axe like the shorter one not that
long axe I guess it's still an axe but
it's just I see what you're saying right
Tomb Raider
where did you go yeah oh you had it all
I had it I just man that you just say oh
I just pooped up at the end yeah you
decided to make it harder for yourself
no way what way sorry we decided to test
the theory that you wouldn't die in one
hit exactly yeah what it was that's a
hundred percent hundred percent do good
another one of these then they change it
all day how do they change it looks very
similar to each other now oh no sneaky I
still think that last puzzle you just
did was harder than this yes these are
still not that tough okay well this one
looks a little bit more complex
leave it deny dog that means puzzled
with twisting guys with axes the careful
will mean that's Tomb Raider flora the
nature is real now it's pretty real
it's been real Sigma Carter for some
would say real good-looking have you
played this on pro I have not had a
chance to play on problem
well the tusk was the symbol of
dominance need that touch what's up
[Music]
you're dead was after the tusk guys
subscribe to you thanks Timothy thanks
for subscribing all now money appreciate
it wasted birdie LD hi guys my name is
Horatio and I like to fight with a
person over how zealous I am you want to
fight it let's go you mean over the
internet chat but this is a little bit
about the story I guess right like
you're kind of let's give it we don't
what's up brah Great Lord ball bail bail
like a Diablo bail let's head back to
the car where is the car where do we
leave it gentleman down there
she's got my way she should be good like
in dauntless you could fall from like
even higher and you take no
all damage all right it's fine realistic
I almost thought you had to do the ax
puzzles again but obviously that would
be you know there would be no way that
wouldn't be fun and making it really
that yeah there we go
so you must be pretty buff to be able
just like one arm pic right and like
might fall off the amount the amount of
climbing they do these games like no way
all right on to the last yeah holy thing
you do a couple of side stuff get some
side action going on here let's see
let's go to there's one right in front
you in front of me Jake Lazo Chloe took
the fast way down that's not birdie that
is not we're not that's not battling
you're just telling me to say stuff
doesn't work telling her story hold on
hold on I have to treasure we got a side
mission real quick Alison I use another
puzzle actually don't want it this one's
actually I'm actually gonna do this one
this one's pretty long okay bear I'm
gonna keep the stream moving but you had
your thinking cap on well I'm taking it
off okay that's fair now maybe you can
tell the rest of her story like that
yeah then for to a way to like continue
the conversation and they add just
little inflections like oh right where
was I or something keeps it going as
mentioned this is a ps4 exclusive house
today wanna play it standalone $39.99
but you also get Uncharted uh-oh
okay you see you through the tall grass
I don't know just getting right into it
though
Oh see you later
pistol Charlie's got shotgun snipers is
his hand cannon sniper boy's problem
come on Nadine I almost gave you that
pre-emptive nice shot but hey the
mommies you're crazy sir
where are you
grenade hello you excuse me as he gets
hit when do you do lashings we do live
streams every day at 11 a.m. Wednesday
is our gaming talk show the lobby
um and then Monday Tuesday Thursday
Friday we livestream pretty much new
games new DLCs new betas alphas when I
start trying to play overwatch a little
bit more potentially some other games so
stay tuned to that obviously if you're
subscribed you guys are gonna get
notification for that you're not
considerate because you know that'll
tell you when we go live and also when
we put up cool content like history goes
right John Luke reviews hot gameplay
preview coverage all that fun stuff
okay propane tank
yeah all right so seems Ferdie LD is
more of a lass of us fan than he he or
she is uncharted I got good news for you
they're making another one don't worry
it's the next game right naughty dogs
got you covered interested to see where
that one goes me too you played that one
you play last of us I've played a little
bit the multiplayer was I somehow played
a little bit more than I liked the
multiplayer it was they found a nice
little twist you know um I'm just like
conventional stuff so right I liked what
they did there so was how I felt about
unsure dudes multiplayer I actually like
I think now maybe a little less special
but like when 2 came out it was like a
lot they incorporated the climbing into
the multiplayer something able to like
scale buildings and flank enemies that
way I like that comment birdie I just
can't say it
yeah we're at we read it we read it
there's a good one I'll let you read it
on yeah why don't you get to that third
one do the third one then you like one
mission of multiplayer where we get to
judge your multiplayer sounds good
I've employed the most people so man tej
Singh yes you could totally buy this
game despite not playing the others it's
a standalone experience I asked this
earlier too
John Luke it does a good job of you know
being its own thing so yeah if you want
to try it out you told you solid
experience nine out of ten
according to Miguel it's one person's
opinion obviously but most of the people
as I mentioned in the office have really
enjoyed this game so yeah definitely
worth a shot if you you don't have
anything else you want to play or
spending money on on the horizon yes oh
hello so do they just roam or was it
because you opened it up cuz I open it
up gotcha but now I have this silenced
pistol Oh what was that noise
like I should have noticed people my
shoulder
get down maybe you need to get to work
evil goatman I'm not sure if we'll play
life is strange before the storm on
stream now that's the kind of thing
where you're gonna plan on a stream you
would play the whole thing yeah yeah
it's tough I mean we already we're kind
of struggling with this one a little bit
but luckily this chapter has something
that's not so story related so that's
why we decided to stream it right cuz
otherwise it's like yeah did you want to
play yourself that's the tough one we
could have just played multiplayer I
guess and that's not new no it's not I
can play better Toph like you know what
Mary did a until dawn look at that point
you're getting pretty much got it you
got to do the whole thing right I don't
want to pay for it I guess you could
just go watch someone else play the
whole thing scene yeah same with the
like tails whole games or games like
life is strange like that's the kind of
thing we go there to watch the whole
playthrough yeah okay where is my car I
know there's a way to find it there is
Batman vision car vision car fishing
now as far as me personally playing life
is strange I will because I quite like
life the strings in Ellie also harkening
what some like it will ever happen I
don't think it happened well I wouldn't
say never never because and that's such
a like say right but I feel like if
anything it's more that PlayStation if
you ever have exclusive right they do PC
to they've done it before Street Fighter
5 that's that's that and PC but then
it's exclusive in the sense that I guess
it's not on the other platform so I
guess I don't know so wouldn't in that
kind of this is this is published by
Sony I guess it's true that's the thing
that's why blood-borne is never gonna be
on another system cuz it's been it was
published by I know it was published you
haven't played blood-borne should do
that thing you're curious about until
dawn you should watch your Mary's
livestream highlights blood-borne still
the best best game of the generation oh
wow wow where my favorites those are
strong words
I remember you weren't here yet but I
remember me might get two more during
game of the year just like no
blood-borne good that guy yeah no we did
we did what happened last year where we
felt so strongly we got it up a position
and then we just gave up at that point
like like we thought we accomplished
something great already by moving it up
when in reality we could've just
probably kept pushing harder
well that's the same what's up this
thing here's Metal Gear yes yeah ok
that's a tough one and rocket League
right you weren't gonna win that fight
alright that's the fun part of game of
the year or the tough part depending how
you look at it and
until dawn was a interesting solid game
somehow it worked out somehow I feel
like that game school yeah I was not
expecting much from that game and when
it came out I was like this is actually
pretty cool and I don't like Quantic
Dream games either which is definitely
kind of what that games inspired by
going heavy rain and I just couldn't get
into that game smack we're not doing any
major story spoilers so that's what we
mean by no spoilers obviously but
spoilers from iboga meal you guys are
the best
thanks nice of you say that is a spoiler
I suppose for the bad jokes now that's
what chats about put good jokes and bad
jokes oh yeah
yeah hey punk I did scare me a couple
times on that until dawn livestream I
also pretended out to be Mary at one
point - that was a weird night pretended
very half-assed oh I had I had a wig on
does that count
I didn't even try after that I couldn't
do it like it was too hard I can't do
Mary's voice that's impossible
you gotta get robbed or Mike yeah you
have you watched that one news update
where we faked that the building was
collapsing and like Rob is like fake
Mary every time like every time like
something that happens because she's
like all do it this not nice
I want until done - what's up Isla hey
or Ella 21 or the other
are you all right we're doing the last
sample here depending on time we might
do a multiplayer map if not why not
there's two of you so I saved my money
for super mario and rabid or odyssey
totally depends very different games if
you're into tactical games like XCOM I
would say Odyssey or sorry Rabbids
battle Kingdom Mario rabbits battle
Kingdom might be more of your jam
actually what I would probably say is
why wouldn't you just buy Rabbids then
sell it after a month I guess or turn it
in and then get Odyssey for half I guess
that would be the compromise unless you
want to keep it which you could do that
too I like keeping games I don't like
selling I know but then some people
don't like that luxury I understand I
think that like that would be the way to
go I don't know I mean obviously I think
the ease like you'll get probably more
bang for your buck with Odyssey I would
imagine
No all right but those are very
different games I feel like even though
they both have Mario onion come on oh
hello
what did idiot and gone come on
no you knock me off of probably probably
Odyssey though I would say I don't know
what about you John like if you had to
pick between the two and I put a gun to
your head like I can never get both no
you can't buy votes yeah probably I'll
receive but I want to play RC there you
go
I wasn't sure both was an option TI but
if both is an option probably both but
they're different
oh good I'm good I should have fallen
James go I'm tempted to buy a switch
from Mario Rabbids I think that it that
would be a cool way right it's like
perfect for that right like once
XCOM came like I like available on iPad
I remember that was like a pretty big
deal like they'll find out pretty soon
like Friday
yeah I think it's this Friday so he's
you this writer
try stealth Annette I'll keep the
receipt for Abbas Mario if I don't like
I'll return it if they let you do that
sure DBZ dude I can't wait for DBZ man
oh man can I not wait for DBZ I think
yeah and the announcement date for that
was February 2018 they didn't specify
exactly when was Dragonball yeah it was
in the end of the trailer with the
androids this morning or last night yes
we said X comma my hardy isn't around
yeah that happens my clothes got lucky
oh that's tough evil go mail I think
that I'm pretty sure I know John Luke's
answer here but I'm gonna ask him
anyways if I had to decide between lost
legacy sorry Uncharted lost legacy or
persona 5 which should I buy I pretty
sure again that's it's like apples and
oranges there dude and like how much
time you would get with persona 5 would
be like god oh yeah it's like a hundred
hours you don't play as needy never know
yeah I just just say no we will not be
playing at people no you get multiplayer
skins for them
oh you got awp I would buy a switch for
breath of the wild that game is amazing
I had a switch for breath of the wild
basically then I sold my switch to Marco
or for Marco rather if anyone remembers
who Marco is was it doesn't seem very
concerned that is how I got shot off
sorry I just felt like you're right in
his line of sight and it's like why
would it
you see you after he gets home yeah get
him a helmet shot off should be the
indicator that something's going on like
oh maybe a bird not my
oh are we clear sweet yeah clear to be
clear well I'll buy persona 5 okay well
there you go also fun fact if you
haven't played any other persona games
there's also a history of persona
eventually I'm just gonna become the
office expert on every video game
franchise yeah that's fine with me it's
fine with us I think why are there so
much killing I don't know I guess
treasure doesn't come free let's see
I'm loving the mid recent mid sized
games hell-blade yeah cuz uh kiwami and
uncharted that Lost Legacy yeah you're
gonna get a cut more of them there's
gonna be that Dishonored
alright definitely outsider it's like
October I want to say I think and I
think there's only three debug
oh it's September 15th oh it's a lot
sooner than you thought oh nevermind is
that it's only thirty I'm gonna find out
for you in just a second cuz I want to
say that it's only thirty which is
pretty cool I don't want to enter my
date of birth
30:29 1980 if it that's so what I
imagine that is it'll probably be a
dishonored one had two DLCs
oh shoot I messed up I jumped too early
I was supposed to like wait for that
cutscene to happen and then reevaluate
panic grenade I did okay you might as
well just like kill myself at that point
I thought I thought I was like oh
they're bad guy that threw a grenade or
don't just actually try to lob a grenade
I tried a lot of grade there we go
you didn't miss much Timothy but uh
sorry back to you decide yeah so so that
had that had to deal sees Nash have done
wall and which is a burger more I don't
think and those are each like $15 each
and they were both really good they they
were like pretty substantial out of like
a lot of new levels people really really
liked him
so if this thing is basically like those
two DLCs just as a standalone thing I'll
be very more like an old hunters kind of
thing like I've won big meaty right
expansion do you'll see instead of like
two smaller ones and if anything I kind
of wish that that was not supposed to
jump that I guess
nailed it if anything I wish that more
deal seeds were like standalone you know
like that kind of wish knife of dunwall
was like a standalone thing or I think
about a BioShock Infinite
remember those two DLCs the return the
rapture ones like I kind of that you
have to still own the game to play those
even though like they could be
standalone and I kind of wish they works
I almost put a deathcounter up but then
that text is way too big and I don't
want to fix it there we go because
that's like five deaths
unacceptable
yeah I think ever since old hunters at
least for me personally I'm like I'd
rather have like one meteor one than
like two small ones that don't feel as
good cuz like I write like with Dark
Souls
I wasn't that big of a fan of the you
know the deal sees the smaller ones and
I was like I wish she just kind of
didn't all the hunters thing we're like
you to do it just like it was long it's
a longer but I just get like long like I
get a one big package instead of like
come we're attached to saying very let's
see what's great yep bear you'll see was
great yeah again I wish I wish it was
kind of a standalone thing broke it just
my dignity alright so here we go
someone's asking if there's any new
mechanics and laws like I see um no
there's no new mechanics in the sense of
like the grappling hook or the climbing
gear
they just incorporate a couple elements
like silenced pistols and like
explosives like dynamite from the
multiplayer into the campaign one
question then I reckon you could all
right we're gonna skip the cinematics
get some do I do now
well I've technically finished a bit
yeah maybe do a multi let's do one
multiplayer map just so you guys see I
guess maybe I don't think I have them I
think I have to put in a code you had
close I'll just play a multiplayer all
right let's play one match multiple
ideas good old times
do you guys know when rocket leaves how
many switch no I don't mean she's
wearing up like a pirate outfit yeah
looks like it
let's see if there's a release date oh
no that's nice
Oh two years ago they just had fall when
they first announced oh is it
yeah so tied this year nice all right
we'll just go with that
Coolio so we're gonna try to play one
uncharted multiplayer game as that does
come with the Lost Legacy expansion deal
seat depending how you look at it so you
can also play multiplayer if you don't
have one charge of 4% a survival mode I
can't read Russian but hopefully that's
hello what's up okay let's go to
customization here's what I got so yeah
so there should be the other characters
but right now I'm just gonna pick boy a
three three version of Chloe and normal
version so India Chloe okay let's see
you don't have enough bucks damn spell
books yeah okay so they do have you can
now play as lost legacy Chloe I'll go
with this normal normal three Chloe all
right I like
yeah okay
let's do a standard oh that's like turn
stuff all the other stuff bounty hunt
your boys end up match classic Uncharted
theme mmm
do plunder just deathmatch oh yeah
fastest one let's see if anyone's
playing now I do notice my rank is zero
or is one I definitely played enough for
him to have a couple ranks so I don't
know what's some of that day one your
day one John Luke do you think if it was
the same thing I would hope it would
carry over my progress if it was the
exact same yeah multi-wire right that is
kind of weird though all right here we
go over under that John Luke does well
just keep my custom though oh so those
are all your load outs yeah my one
custom loadout I made here's all the
alternate load outs we try some weird
ones all right here we go
suck it other team that we can't see oh
there you go oh man some of them got
some crazy stuff on man oh yeah they get
they get weird with the multiplayer
Cosmetics
they didn't add the ranking system until
a month or so after and Trevor four came
out but I'm sure you did you play after
the pack I'm sure you did right if I
played how much more I play it after a
month
that's why Oh watch out here we go class
constructing and I wasn't sure to choose
theme I believe look alive
okay it's been a while you guys oh how
do you meet these guys ready for this
all right nice didn't die either so I
did play a fair amount of chu and threes
multiplayer for my Uncharted history of
I can still found people playing oh
really
yeah um pretty much only deathmatch I
couldn't play like any of the objective
modes tougher and I couldn't always get
full matches but still found people
since I'm doing the Assassin's Creed
history of I was trying to find
multiplayer matches for Assassin's Creed
if not so hot nope I totally found one
right away oh the Brotherhood the one
the first one that had multiplayer on
ps3 got to match right away please
yeah it was actually woody cool that's
like interesting in itself it is I'm
glad I mean I'm still able to play those
because it's like an aspect I want at
least you know touch on right I'm not
finding anybody yet
do you guys think crossovers or cooling
games crossovers like crossover
characters I want to say that's I guess
be more specific
Eva go ma'am I'm all about that put some
link in my that was not gonna go well
the second I swung they knew you know
link in my soul calibur Darth Vader in
my also Soul Calibur a lot of Soul
Calibur Ezio slow caliber five never so
going back to Assassin's Creed haven't
done one of those in a while I like they
have nice last one I haven't played one
a long time that's when I actually
played played was for my mind a bit two
or three that's how long it's been
what was the first time they had Rafael
Rafael or whatever there's the fencing
guy I don't know and that's the last one
oh is that that guy Oh next level
tactics
how can you revive him
oh nice it's like poke do you got a
LeBron James what I got here
how's your team doing we're losing all
right guys join the natural because we
shouldn't be losing this plague
what's up already oh damn sniper I the
LBJ is not messing around
we came to finish you off to you James
Cromwell so I was sad that input
multiplayer in the Uncharted collection
me too I would have liked that well I
think we're just gonna end on that
really Oh fine I'll give you one more
one more one more one more
fine fine we'll give him a chance
give me one more chance give him a
chance at the beginning this was untrue
to multiplayer I'd whip everyone okay
that's fair I got in that first match I
got I had 17 kills I dominated huh nice
I just checking on stream because
someone was saying it now we're good
hope it's fine for use in Ellie she
should be fine though like different
like characters from different games
meet I don't know I mean like I think it
works when it's like as John we've
mentioned when you're just having kind
of like these cameos or guest
appearances like Mortal Kombat had a
leather face and stuff like that right I
thought that was fine because they were
able to find a way to incorporate them
into the game without breaking the game
what's up John power def are you doing
today thanks for tuning in
all right here's your chance okay your
one chance can't mess it up no well yeah
thank you guys again for all time we're
going to Scotland we are playing on
charter Lost Legacy we're just showing
off some multiplayer we we did some
open-world exploration earlier Chapter
four
I think chapter four mhm didn't do heavy
spoilers or anything so if you you know
obviously or you guys would have left
probably sooner but yeah solid game
$39.99 nine out of ten
migaila concepción and out today ps4 so
if you're into uncharted games obviously
you're probably playing if you're on the
fence hopefully maybe this swayed you
into potentially buying it who knows or
maybe you're just watching two other
streamers finish the whole thing and you
don't have to play at all just possible
to try tactical here get to ACTA coal
you want to be in on the action huh I do
this she says I want to be in the action
John Luke where's the action the action
is loading okay
oh yeah also as a side note just in case
you guys haven't noticed already but
games cons happening and I've been doing
a bunch of coverage on Gamescom so you
know check that stuff out and there will
be more stuff coming out throughout the
week that guys naked or mostly make it
Daft Punk over there yeah parently
pretty cool I like it you got like
almost like a yeah they they got weird
with the multiplayer skits they're like
you have license to do whatever you want
I remember they added like hotline bling
is like an emote kind of thing right
yeah get that in destiny - that's
correct or some sweet pay to look good I
mean mom just playing like vanilla Chloe
yep repping that are you guys both
sniping
how do you get your tan skin Scots I'd
do the opposite of what I do
stay inside I love staying inside though
me too
that's why my skin is not tan here we go
here we go we're looking for someone
looking for a guy so far three two to
the game seems more even this match
making our way to the red base
essentially they're not spotting I'm not
seeing any people where's this hot spawn
camp action fast too furious Oh three I
feel like he wanted too fast too furious
and wasn't able to get it dude that that
is the the the one thing I really wish I
could do on PSN name yep I would mean as
crappy as it sounds
cuz I don't really want to pay for it
but I would actually pay like 10 bucks
to change my name
real talk bummer
nice save them well sort of yeah Nathan
Drake to having is my favorite thing
about uncharted multiplayer so random
barrel of it dabbing the one thing that
I thought would eventually dine has not
died off if anything it's increased this
this theory to III was a the year of
Davin uh yeah Bob Jones this is slowly
turning into a one more stream that's
how it goes I mean I've done it on many
a stream like a neo and stuff like that
I'm just like no no I got the boss real
close it's just just one more time
and then it becomes like half an hour
later but this is really just one time
so far it's been good though he's he's
definitely redeeming himself not fun in
people that was the problem seems like
your team is doing work oh damn dang it
I didn't
oh hello there's some rubber-banding
going on there that I'm not very into
not into that that was a little weird oh
yeah
oh yes it's perfect
what a great spawn we're getting we're
gonna get into the thick of it right
here ah oh yeah I was gonna lose to that
why was that not bad though he's got a 1
for 1 ratio that's all guys what's up
Bella
Lucas ski try this one there's a lot of
weapons in here that I haven't messed
with they've added so matter what you
got like a famous yeah or the art or the
was the p90 you know this is uncharted
lost legacy but we're currently playing
multiplayer so it's technically in
charter for but we were playing lost
legacy the newest kind of standalone
game from Naughty Dog whoa that was very
awkward
hmm I'll get this one Wars right but is
that guy in the buff
nah I don't know he's like in sort of
the buff he's in party mode how many
videos do you do for a day it's not it
wouldn't just be us what a decent amount
because like we also publish publisher
assets as well which are like trailers
like that like what like what do you
think like ten over ten a day probably
something like that give me some money
definitely it's not easy Heiser to play
and watch at the same time so we
appreciate that you are watching and
also playing the game too oh really Wow
something commitment what he's trying to
tell me got that treasure
oh here we go sneaking up to the back
side of the base following the gut party
guy oh boy Oh surprise oh I also want to
watch kick me yeah there we go real bad
oh we going shotgun again up close and
personal I don't typically go shotgun
with this game but alright see see seems
like there's some keys in close quarters
keep it together
yeah keep you together down barrel roll
laughing there we go how sloppy Oh some
got his power out Impala's that was the
one thing I was gonna
our weird power stuff but I guess you
got to add something to mix it up right
yeah but by the time you get to 4 you've
done the multiplayer three times doing
something new so that's what the classic
mode does it disables that if you don't
want any of that stuff
all right losing ten by ten still doable
not great it's not a landslide you're
rocking the shotgun still mm-hmm fries
oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah we're you guys
Oh BAM - turn around oh yeah this guy
right there - what an idiot
oh my yeah all right good thing we gave
him that one more huh guys
Oh No now he's getting John Lucas
feeling himself here we go hey yo King
we're catching up sort of got here your
left
here we go shotgun Oh heads up grenade
oh did you just need three of them
alright it's all up to you John hell's
good run that's a good little run though
hopefully you can spawn before your team
loses it for you
dang whoa philanthropy John Luke please
think of the children
Oh gotta save them yeah yeah yeah all
right they got one oh what a cheater
he's got like a good launcher like a man
[ __ ] a man you jerk Oh
all right man that was good that was
good I lost but I personally came back
that's a clippable moment though is what
matters there that's how I look that was
a clippable moment as he watching over
on twitch so thank you guys all for
watching
that wasn't our last legacy obviously
the multi players like pretty sickly
uncharted 4 but you get that with the
standalone
39.99 available today ps4 only obviously
thank you John Luke good job there at
the end thank you be stood there and
stay tuned tomorrow of course we have
the lobby at 11 a.m. so you know
obviously tune in for that we're gonna
be talking probably some lost legacy and
for some reason some of this oh I think
I think Rob's up allowed to talk about
something I still have to talk about Cod
he's a lot of talk about comic-con have
Game Boy a - and yeah we have gameplay
up as you mentioned so we'll have that
also on the lobby and the third game is
eluding me right now for some reason I
brought something but check that out
tomorrow
obviously John link will probably on
I'll be switching proof you guys all
tuning in again
every day at eleven and see you guys
tomorrow bye bye bye
[Music]